منتجنا
أجرى بحثًا مقدامًا للعثور
على مرتكب تلك
القبلة واسمك جيني
آه ما دار في ذهنك في تلك
اللحظة عندما رأيت الملك الجديد
جاء العدل لقد رأيته في المقدمة لي
لم أستطع
صدقها وقلت له هل لي أن أقبلك وأقول
حسنًا ، لذا أمسكت به وأنا سعيد
جدًا جدًا ، شكرًا لك يا إلهي ، سمحت لي
برؤيته وأقبله كيف شعرت
عندما رأيته لماذا فعلت ذلك؟  أريد أن أفعل
ذلك ،
أنا أحب العائلة المالكة
دائمًا ، فأنا
أشاهدهم
بتذكارات من الأطفال الصغار حتى يكبروا ،
هل فكرت يومًا في أنك ستقبل ملكًا
على الشفاه ، لا
لا ، لم يخطر ببالي أبدًا ،
لقد بدا مرتاحًا ، أليس كذلك؟  أعني
التفكير في ما كان يقوله كان
يبدو حزينًا ، وأقول آسف لما تحبه تقوله
، نعم ، وأقول هل لي أن أقبله جيدًا كيف
نعم ولماذا كنت تفعل ذلك
لتهدئته لطمأنته أم أنه مجرد
شعور قد تغلب  هذا هو
الشعور في الواقع ، نعم ، لم أفكر أبدًا في
أي شيء آخر
يا إلهي  في المقدمة ، حسنًا ،
أعتقد أنه كان من المشجع جدًا
أن يرى رد فعل الحشود
هناك الدفء ، نعم ، هل
شعرت أنه كان يريحه ،
أعتقد ذلك ، نعم ، لأنه كان يبتسم جيدًا ،
نعم ، نعم  لا أقول مثل
هذا أو أي شيء ، إنه
مبتسم جميل ومذهل